the poet lavalle Druckman once said
blessed are the curious for they shall
have adventures which is certainly true
of people with wanderlust derived from a
German word meaning a love of hiking and
now used to describe that burning near
physical desire to escape the everyday
and explore the unfamiliar and
insatiable appetite of a travel
wanderlust is a common but not universal
experience what makes some people catch
that travel book while others are
apparently immune one theory is to do
with our genes scientific research has
identified a variant of the drd4 gene
sounds like a livable space robot but
it's actually the gene that affects
sensitivity to dopamine the
neurotransmitter often released in the
brain when we do something we enjoy now
it's not that the 7-hour version of the
drd4 specifically creates a craving for
travel but people with the 7/r variant
are less sensitive to that delicious
dopamine hit so simple things that bring
other people pleasure like a jog in the
park or a cheeky chocolate binge might
not cut it for them which makes those
with the 7/r type of the drd4 gene more
likely to be risk-takers and
thrill-seekers going further than most
of us sometimes literally to get
increased dopamine levels
that's why drd4 7r has been called the
wonder lust gene the important thing
about genes is that they don't determine
anyone's personality all sorts of
factors play into that but given that
other research has linked the same 7 are
variants of far riskier behaviors such
as addiction a short temper and
delinquent behavior the repressible
impulse to go into railing seems like
the better end of the Darwinistic deal
so genetics may come into play when it
comes to discerning the wild at heart
from the home bodies but another theory
looks at the psychology of living in our
modern interconnected human society a
society in which we are constantly aware
of what family friends and social media
influences are doing the psychologist
Leon Festinger
called this social comparison theory
a theory that was later developed by
academics to describe two distinct ways
we compare ourselves to other people
upwards social comparisons comparing
ourselves to those we see is more
successful than us and downward social
comparisons comparing ourselves to those
we see is worse off than us in the age
of social media it's very easy to
compare ourselves unfavorably with the
idealized version how can we compete
with influences with their perfectly
tanned legs on immaculate white sand and
their once-in-a-lifetime sunsets / Machu
Picchu hashtag no filter
hashtag living their best lives whether
the motivation to explore the world is
genetic psychological or something else
there are far more harmful hobbies than
the desire to explore the world
venturing outside your comfort zone to
learn about new cultures meet people you
might otherwise never have had the
chance to meet and ultimately learn who
you are in different situations
sounds like a life well-lived as the
novelist Jack Kerouac said because in
the end you won't remember the time you
spent in the office or mowing your lawn
climb that goddamn mountain thanks for
watching don't forget to subscribe and
click the bail to receive notifications
for new videos see you again soon